[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I did oh she's just full she was awake
the whole way pretty much it's beautiful
just falling asleep princess get up say
yeah you daddy you happy to see daddy
really come to Daddy for a cutoff daddy
for kiddo
all right so should do a house tour do
you want to you want to be the leader of
the house talk cuz I don't remember
where anything is I remember I picked
this house because I thought it looked
amazing I love things like this light
color on the outside it's just different
normally I choose the investment houses
but then our home where we live pretty
much yeah I'm in touch I get to choose I
get issues we I mean last time I viewed
the last house and you never saw it
until we moved in but luckily money's
got a pretty good taste just gorgeous
man
massive she walk around the outside can
you walk around it all so you can walk
around the house which is pretty cool
and round to the back there's a bit of
like patio area like this and then
there's also a play area because the
family that lived here they had two kids
and can you hear that
that's his bass as loud as the plains
I can hear a plane but it's so faint we
were in Richmond we're thinking that
we're almost going to move to Richmond
the problem of Richmond was man even
when you in Richmond Park there's just
constant Plains going over really low
and from one mental peace
I just liked home working I like the
hustle and bustle but at home it's just
chill out so it's nice and quiet here
it's peaceful so this is the back garden
really really nice and all the doors
along the back of the house we're all by
fault doors so you can open them a
selling point for me of this house you
know you know that's a palm tree palm
tree in your backyard and it just feels
this is gonna feel like a 24/7 holiday
yeah palm trees around the garden man
but fun busy
so private gates top security CCTV
everywhere not that you get robbed
anyway because this place to be honest
is just like
probably the safest place to live on the
planet almost especially if your your
you'll be security wait your movie all
right so let's go inside then I'll show
you around the inside there into the
front hello
welcome MTV Cribs things I like about it
is that it's just so open and
transparent you know everything's just
opened up spacious clean it's great
formal sitting room I don't know where
the light switch is but yeah this will
be adults only space no kids sir again
it leads on but this is just for the
tour yeah just for the tour but yes so
we're gonna have yeah just so seating in
here now question is is where we're
gonna have my studio where are they
another in the little office downstairs
or more on the main rooms upstairs so we
need to figure out where we're gonna
have the studio because we need I need I
want to be able to invite people around
my house like success students friends
peers mentors and interview them and
have them like I know on my YouTube
channel and I wanted that home and on
Tibet to have them have a chat have a
drink so we need a room that's kind of
what set up for that I think this should
be my studio cuz it do you reckon
upstairs
this room the adult lounge slash studio
people can edit lounge slash
[Music]
yeah but every time we're in the adult
lounge you can just record I honestly
think that listen just just hear my
argument
I honestly think in this room I mean I
only exploring the possibility what do
you want this room to be okay give me an
example like like with her just just to
[Music]
like her like it and which I have I mean
I don't know what the cell would be but
if it was a studio it would be a really
Pleasant pleasing to the eye place for
cameras and stuff the cameras will be in
the callers but we just have more ya
know nobody wouldn't it wouldn't know
everybody wouldn't we just do different
at the moment I would just film in the
lounge
you blow that
yep you can't go because there's lights
and mics and well I guess then it
depends on what kind of studio we have
if we have a studio that's got like a
backdrop and light and stuff like that
then this room is not going to work if
we have just a really nice Pleasant
always clean tidy a lounge feel Lounge
feel and we have cameras in there all
the time but backdrop lights just
cameras but then they just off maybe oh
no what do you think Amelia how many how
many frigging rooms how many I don't
think I would see you sittin in that
living room even then this is like an
adult working like a working room like
an adult nice neat working room filming
studying a laptop at all
that's this room which would include
filming which include studio type stuff
just a thought exactly how it is exactly
exactly tidy clean for filming exactly
incentive eyes meet want it to be
tidying clean even more so because there
could be feels really cameras boobs well
it's always gonna be this room whatever
what you think a minute you can talk
wall on the camera do you think this
room could be good
is there an echo that one server but but
if we put a rug would that stop it or
not I don't like the echo not but they
knew you could probably change that but
where would you have it would you have
it like if I was interviewing someone
would you put the mics here and then
where was this video video be like a
camera like here and then we could have
a lot all our books and stuff here
trophies stories manuals photos like the
whole library of business books would
the kind of work being there that would
it be to close it with yeah well should
we see the upstairs one so this will
just be like open space right yeah I
think we should have like a like a so
for us some seating
I want a big circle table here with like
a big bars and flowers so the kitchen is
so light and bright and I never actually
noticed that these doors are transparent
I love that they're not transparent they
are opaque but they're glass that's
pretty cool
I looked at all the doors slides so it's
not like you have a great big door
coming into the room and taking up space
but I think we'll have some seating in
here as well I think we could either
have like a breakfast table and a sofa
just over there or we could have like a
nice cool corner so far there come on a
sofa all the way and then we need some
stools here so you can just sit down
have some food
I think that's gonna look really good I
like that I love the idea of having a
sofa here corner sofa and then in here
this is like gonna be the family
friendly yeah family friendly the kids
can have the toys in here we'll have to
have a good storage system yeah so this
is the family room and noticed that this
TVs in the other rooms need to have a TV
in here and I like the fact that you can
just open this up totally and then the
kids can just go in and now it's just
noise go and play on the swings we can
see them yeah yeah yeah we're just
finding a new bathroom
yeah yeah what's in there oh nice
utility room what would you actually use
the utility room father and we need to
decide what we want to tell the interior
designer in regards so we kind of have a
better idea for my advice you got this
nice I love it up here
it just feels so big doesn't it so it's
just so open but I've seen bigger houses
of course some houses are big but
they're compartmentalized but this is
just yeah
all right this is the other potential
studio yep
now if this was our studio Amelia we
could do whatever we want to it because
you reckon yeah even this is best yeah
why because I feel like it's ready
together ready for us to start
decorating and I don't know whether it's
bigger but maybe because they just
haven't got the fit is much bigger than
the big one but what about the big one
the big room yeah
yes that's your lounge though you think
it'd be trying to kill two birds which
is not good
Ivy it's good to have one specific
filming room there's always felt ready
to go whenever yeah and then obviously
if you take cameras around the houses I
said what you suggest that this room
looks like mummy you look so happy about
yeah
I think I think I think that's right
though I think it's better to just have
this one room let's just set up all the
time can come in he can sit down it just
starts filming not like say if I had my
friend round and then you want to do
filling but I want to sit in the adult
section for whatever reason yeah that's
what problems okay so how will this
studio at that Amelia what what are you
thoughts you can have like so you have
different setups they almost tell other
people doesn't seem like one were you
definitely youtubers do they have a set
where they like doing like I might get
ready when we make up and then they have
another set where they'd like doing oh I
don't know
sit down triumph or something yeah
literally fair we have like different
rooms a different set up it's like only
different room but you're not you just
you just got on Facebook without me
could we have that something as well
could we have two studios yeah if you
have room for you you know doing
anything else
that can be really cool we could do the
and downstairs one like either cheese
and we'll have one is there you know you
wanted a more chilled background but
really like cool we can choose one
that's really cool different things in
the background and we can have one
that's more like the podcast a corn of
qat Sunday here yeah we need one there's
more professional more and we need one
that's like very cool can I have a
different kind of video I think that's
what we should do and what I had all the
cool texture yeah and so that could be
like why do the social media kind of
stuff yeah yeah
lighting perspective from a background
backdrop audio-visual all that stuff how
would this room how much this room work
so I was thinking this could maybe be
the cooler room
I think downstairs is better for life
because there's more window space but
with filming you can either use natural
light and then put a few artificial or
you can just set the whole room yourself
and I think with this one could
potentially be one where we just set the
lighting for the whole room artificially
yeah potentially obviously you might
have a few where like you can get the
Sun and I think but majority I'd say if
you're in that corner we can't really
use that so we're just we would just put
the blind everything's gonna be a slush
yeah this is my toy toys bedroom right
well the mental inspector so also it's
really cool because Luke's never six
months so Luke's moving out moves
getting Luke's getting evicted from
living without
like this is getting a little bedroom
risk what do you think huh he seems a
bit more you have lik d-lighting bedroom
so this could be a Jew room if an
ensuite in that oh yeah I love all these
guest rooms we're gonna have to fry some
but there are some wild parties here
[Music]
[Music]
for this oh it's probably 12 all the
blinds whoa ah nice keep it on the
neighborhood yeah so bit more space than
the one that we've got out of there mate
ha girls through yeah it was dream for
sure I love it we can like just assign
that bit to Samuel city but yeah you
never better ahead but it was really
under the bed yeah
I said I'll assign you a little section
of the wardrober than the rest can just
be right sounds about right
music music waving laughs yeah really
so in this house ticks all the boxes
yeah great schools you know lovely walks
around super close to the center really
really fast to get to understand my 2016
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you